qu'il est ici
écoute juin sujet à vous proposez vous
savez la doré avec la mineure une
guérison potentiellement divine une
fille qui fait des miracles après avoir
été visité par la vierge marie
chicago new york washington dans tous
les pays du monde les médias s'arrachent
cet événement donnez-moi l'exclusivité
ok ça y est ça est en place que d'études
de commencer par deux trois questions
très simples combien de personnes vont
regarder marie veut toucher le plus de
personnes possible peut-être des
millions
[Musique]
il ya certaines personnes qui ne croient
pas à des miracles qu'est ce que tu
aurais envie de leurs biens
[Musique]
voir c'est croire voilà ce que je dirai
pourquoi penses-tu que marie thé choisir
j'ai ouvert mon coeur à marie je les ai
accueillis en or
les apparitions de la vierge marie
attire des millions de fidèles chaque
année le vatican est chargé d'enquêter
sur ces manifestations de la sainte
vierge
j'ai lu l'équivalent de plusieurs
bibliothèques douvres h le paranormal
j'ai conduit six enquêtes sur des
miracles
j'ai prouvé qu'ils étaient tous four
[Applaudissements]
il est ici
est ce que tu crois qu'il y à d'autres
forces en jeu ici quand vieux bâti une
église le démon bat une chapelle à côté
ne doutez pas des no doubt à
février-mars fois
[Musique]
il plein de grâce
pauvre pêcheur maintenant ouailles à
l'heure de notre mort
ce n'est pas l'oeuvre de la vie et le
chômage
c'est celle que ballard
la femme des mains amplifie ses pouvoirs
avait foi en elle
auprès de votre âme
amari
cette marie mère de dieu
le seigneur est avec vous